welcome to a fresh take on the news
putting you at the center of the
national conversation about the issues
that matter to you most
tonight a european country remains under
fierce attack from an authoritarian
neighbor as a balance of power around
the world shifts
with spheres of influence realigning is
the world as we know it changing
i'm trevor phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
[Applause]
each week we go to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
tonight nearly a month on from the
invasion of ukraine our viewers from
across the country and across the world
will tell their stories and have their
stay
here in the studio our expert panel this
week is
tim marshall author of several
best-selling books on foreign affairs
and international diplomacy including
the power of geography
from south carolina rose godemolo
former deputy secretary general of nato
and lecturer in international security
and cooperation at stanford university
travel writer and filmmaker ash bardwice
whose adventures include traveling eight
and a half thousand kilometers through
european countries along russia's border
and cindy you host of the chinese
whispers podcast at the spectator
the big question tonight how is vladimir
putin's war changing the world
we have to stand up for a core principle
that lies at the heart of the
international order
russia is a regional power that is
threatening
some of its immediate neighbors not out
of strength but out of weakness
democracy is precious
democracy is fragile the ukrainians and
the russians take pot shots in the woods
each and every soldier who has committed
this war crime by order or not will be
held as constable
there is the so-called liberal idea
which has outlived its purpose
u.s lawmakers are captivated by this man
being the leader of the world means to
be the leader of peace this is a turning
point for the world it's a choice
between freedom
and oppression
[Music]
okay let's start as always with our
viewers panel and talk to
cat el caru cat
hi good evening everyone um
i'm watching my children become more and
more disenchanted with the world they're
aware of man-made war and man-made
climate change
i've tried to explain the war in ukraine
to my 16 12 and 8 year old boys but
there's really no explanation other than
power and greed
and an inability to protect vulnerable
people in a meaningful way
my 16 year old has even said he'd go and
fight in ukraine he wants to fight to
stop war right so but in a world where
democratic leaders can't come together
to stop death spots like putin
causing the destruction that he's
already caused
is democracy worth fighting for
well that's a that's a question for
everybody whatever age you are thank you
cat let's come to
that question
is democracy worth fighting for
rose guatemala what's the answer what
are you going to tell young people
absolutely yes
their lives so far have really benefited
from the stability and the
uh the abundance that has come after
world war ii because we've had stable
democratic systems particularly in
europe and uh my heart goes out to the
the children of your your first viewer
who spoke because of course suddenly
seeing that world shaken so close to
home right in the center of europe must
be terribly terribly worrying we see of
course war and and
uh extremist attacks all over the world
but and then i'm a little ashamed
sometimes we don't pay as much attention
to them but honestly this war in the
heart of europe seems to be upending
all of what we have achieved since world
war ii and so i would say yes that
system is absolutely worth fighting for
and it's not just about economic
prosperity but it's about the ability to
live together in a way where we don't
have to fight so i really think that we
need to do everything we can to advance
this uh effort to support the ukrainians
thank you rose uh tim marshall
it's somebody else's country is it
really worth it
yes uh because we are fighting uh for
the future
and the support that's going to it is
not just to support ukraine it is to
support the democratic world because if
this does fall
then it shows that
might is right
the aggression will pay off
and the big picture is
and you alluded to it in the
introduction
there is now i believe an acceleration
towards what i thought was already
happening
which is the authoritarian world
of which putin is part of
china and other countries
and then not the west i think that's an
outdated concept but the advanced
industrialized democracies including
places like japan
taiwan
south korea and on western europe yes
this is not just about west east this is
about the authoritarian countries
and the democracies with all their
faults all right let me come back to you
cat
um
how do you explain it to your
children and can you have you persuaded
them um
yeah i've persuaded them that
democracies worse fighting for but i
think that they're troubled by the
amount of destruction
that has happened
so we hear about sanctions but putin has
already destroyed ukraine
its infrastructure its buildings
people that go back will have to take
years to rebuild that country so they
don't see this as a win already they
don't see it as a win now
okay thank you thank you cat i want to
um
talk to chris roberts
um
chris i think you're in the iron man
square what what's your view
about this
is it worth it is it worth the battle
yeah of course it's worth the battle as
your
other uh contributors have just
mentioned for all those reasons
i think when you speak about changing
the world or changing the future one of
the things we have to be aware of is
the cold war the cold war finished in
1991
i think
that will re-emerge out of this whatever
happens in ukraine but this time around
that
putin's got other weapons he hasn't just
got conventional weapons or wmd he's got
the weapons of social media he's got the
disinformation
energy and food supply econom the
economy
of that
and that's going to affect everybody in
the world not just the west
okay chris thank you
let me come back in studio cindy you
um
the stakes here
are high
but are they in your view as high as i
think
being made out by everybody here
this grand battle between democracy and
authoritarianism yes i think it was
always thus ever thus you know i think
democracy if we think about it in our
world is such a new concept and it's a
brilliant concept but modern democracy
as we know it even in the west is only a
few hundred years old and that's why
it's so valuable because for the first
time in thousands of years of human
history you know there is this
real freedom of speech for ordinary
people um and you know going back to
your previous
caller's question is it worth fighting
for you know as a chinese person i think
look at this war and i think if it
happened with china and i was
disagreeing with the war i couldn't say
that within china and that would be
something deeply held and you couldn't
say that look at china's zero cover
policy now it's completely arbitrary
lockdowns when they happen people have
very little recourse to changing that
policy because there is no freedom of
speech there is no accountability for
the government and so when you put
yourself in that situation democracy is
absolutely worth fighting for i guess my
point is just authoritarians are not
going anywhere they're always going to
be with us i believe especially when
you've got the history the complicated
history and the cultures of the
countries involved here and so
all we can do is try to co-exist and try
to protect democratic interests wherever
possible
and not think we can eradicate the other
side
there's a problem here isn't it that
potentially
there's one bad guy who is running one
rogue nation
and
we might solve it or we might not solve
it but is this something that's going to
change the world because they've been
bad guys before
well i'm hearing what kat was saying
about speaking to her kids and
the way they were feeling about wanting
to go and defend ukraine
when i was in ukraine noting just how
much people wanted to defend their
democracy there they tasted tyranny
under the previous president and they
gained freedom and i think
by setting good examples and allowing
places like ukraine to
stand as good light against tyranny
that's the way that we can start to
set a competition against autocracy and
i think that's the way we can do it by
making sure that places that have found
freedom they get to keep it
all right let's go back to war and talk
to um joe constant joe
eden trevor good evening joe what's your
view
uh putin could be setting a precedence
in the terms of deciding which country
to overrule and take control knowing
full well there will be no recourse due
to fears of the third world war
in 2014 russia demonstrated similar
behavior with the crimea war so this is
not the first time
since then the west could have done more
but everyone fears antagonizing putin
and is why they just sat on their hands
okay so hold on there for a second joe
let's talk to julie faye
julie is in i think you're in chicksby
julie what what do you make of this
well i'm puzzled um so many people
possibly even russia
have been surprised that russian forces
have so far failed on the ground
and we have this impression of this uh
vast army they parade on red square and
we have this impression of a
well-equipped vast army but
what we're seeing does not match that
image
that's a very interesting point let's
come back rose gotta mother um this is
an interesting point um certainly on the
ground the russians don't seem to have
done
the damage or made the advances that
people thought they might have done
indeed they thought they might have done
are we put in danger you've been uh
number two at nato are we in danger of
overestimating
their impact on the situation
i think they're really two factors here
one i'm going to differ with your viewer
a bit a lot has been done since 2014
ukraine as a good partner of nato in our
partnership for peace program was
undergoing a lot of transformation in
its armed forces yes they were defeated
by the russians in 2014 taken by
surprise but they learned a lot from
that experience they've also been
fighting russian forces in donetsk and
lucance in the east part of the country
so they accumulated a huge amount of
combat experience and savvy
in the intervening few years and that is
one reason why the russians are bogged
down so seriously the other points to i
think a really deep problem in russia is
corruption they poured so much money
into modernizing the russian armed
forces but in the end of the day
their fearsome armed forces haven't
looked so good on the ground with things
like the tires blowing out because they
were
cheap chinese tires that somebody got on
discount i suppose so there are issues
like that as well and the lack of good
planning the lack of logistics the lack
of enough petrol to keep running all of
these things i think point to the fact
that the russians did not come to this
fight well prepared okay let's come back
to julie um julie
rose is just making the point that
actually a lot has changed in the last
few years and that though
the russians might look a bit
bit rocky they are actually a much
greater force than they
than they were
even in 2014
uh yes i was listening to the points
that rose made about um the
not being very well equipped
not having that much strategy about
things
and um listening to your uh footage at
the beginning of the program with barack
obama saying that they are a regional
country fighting regional opponents
um i wouldn't want to estimate
underestimate russia for one minute
but i'm just wondering where the truth
and the reality actually match up
okay
tim
truth versus reality
they are formidable military power still
they've got this so badly wrong
but it a fish rots from the head
on february 24th more than 50 percent of
russia's foreign reserves were still
outside of the country
that tells you that he had not told the
economic class
even in secret what was coming if he
didn't tell the economic class he didn't
tell half of his military they didn't
have the plan that he wanted them to
then fulfill
briefly also what has been happening in
the last seven years as well as all the
things that rose has said i think it's
very important to point out britain sent
at least 2 000 end laws these are the
new generation anti-tank weapons
in the run-up to this war america sent a
couple of thousand javelins and these
are the things that have been taking out
the russian armor there was a lot done
for ukraine over the past few years
short of
actually being there as well okay i just
wanted to emphasize trevor was the other
way around i was saying that since 2014
ukrainians have really trained up very
very well working uh very hard to build
up their armed forces with the help of
nato in partnership with nato it's the
russians that i think have really fallen
down in this fight
okay thank you let's go back to our
viewers panel and talk to
jonathan bother and i think you
have a view about the way this is
changing the rest of the world
you know trevor
i really think that what we have here is
a crisis um i'm not trying to be
alarmist or anything but um i've been
doing a lot of research just personally
on the states of democracy around the
world and tim raised a very good point i
think that
talking about the west
is is a very antiquated idea i think
it's better for us to look at the idea
of freedom
and you know more specifically liberal
democracy and what it is that we stand
for and
every year freedom house puts out a
document which basically outlines the
it's like a litmus test for
what
democracy looks like around the world
and they give it a score
and what we've seen is that over the
past 16 years
that score has consistently gone lower
and in fact eight out of ten people do
not live in any sort of democracy at all
so only 20 percent of people live in a
democracy we are in fact going to go on
to talk about exactly that point the
clash between authoritarians and
democracy so coming up after the break
we're talking superpowers and whether we
miss the signs of a changing world order
long before the ukraine invasion
russia and china are fashioning a new
world order regarding our bilateral
relations they are indeed developing
steadily in the spirit of friendship and
strategic partnership for vladimir putin
it is perhaps more important than it is
for xi jinping china india brazil
argentina mexico
i am sure these countries do not want
to be just in a position when uncle sam
orders them something and they say yes
sir
ukrainian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center of
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
look at that sheet of flavor and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
mr trump james james matthews from sky
news hey james
[Music]
i'm james matthews and i'm skye's
scotland correspondent
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate how is
vladimir putin's war changing the world
after the end of the cold war a general
consensus emerged about the power
balance around the world or so we
thought but while we in the west were
perhaps looking inwards distracted by
issues like brexit or trump's victory
did we miss the signs of changing
priorities for others
let's talk to musa india from our
viewers panel
musa you i think have a view about
what's been happening in the rest of the
world and the way that they view it
my question is um
is who's defined the new world order
that's my question because if you look
at for example in in in in africa as he
said in one order i mean china is now
dominating african trade and that's
based on because africa needed
infrastructure they needed people who
invest in the country and china is just
giving them what they want in comparison
to european countries which is offering
democracy but the african day more into
getting jobs and getting trade
so i think that's europe need to review
um i think the
okay yeah that's a clear question so now
mrs question for our panel is
who is defining the new world order
and cindy a lot of fingers are pointing
at china now
yeah but i think china is not leading
the world order just yet uh it wants to
certainly wants to challenge the
existing world order and to muscle's
question you know who defines it i think
it's the institutions that this world
lives under because we are in a stage
where we do
pay heed to the u.n to the wto to the
wha to the imf all of these
international institutions that were
built up during the 20th century under
time when the west was undeniably in
dominance you know they were able to set
the rules and when america doesn't like
a certain rule it can find the certain
loopholes and that's the kind of
privilege that china wants to have not
necessarily to tell everyone else what
to do but to be able to change the rules
when it suits them um and that's the
kind of challenge that it wants to do to
give to the world order but i don't
think it's quite there yet and i don't
think it will be there with china and
russia replacing america and
the uk perhaps it's never going to be
that easy but
china is going to be patient it sounds
like it's going to wait
yes i mean i think china you know
chinese people like to talk about 5 000
years of history i mean almost certainly
a political narrative it was certainly
not 5 000 years of history but it likes
to see itself as long a long game the
question though is does president xi
think he has that much time you know
he's 69 years old this year he begins
his third term in government uh probably
president for life he wants to set a
legacy he wants to be the next model he
wants that kind of legacy and that's why
he's putting on the pressure for taiwan
which the russian war has scuppered
and and that's why he actually for him
there is a counting clock for his legacy
okay let's delve into this a little bit
further uh and talk to ching chu buu um
i think you have a view about
china's strategy
a
yes
indeed it's a very critical time
and no doubt at all
the world relies on china for threat
this is called global supply chain
but economic dependencies could be
exploited for political games
and as we always say whether china is a
real superpower
and it depends on
whether
it has
stopped we can super influence on global
affairs and global governance
so in the current
ukraine conflict and so far
china has now taken significant action
but the world is watching to see what
china does next i just want to
pick up this this point you're making
with paul dejan on who actually is from
panama paul
what is your view about this about this
new power rising
in the east as people keep saying
yeah well in latin america um the
relationship with china goes back and
with some countries a long time a long
way but most recently um i think uh 20
years ago when uh chairman of china
hojin tower i think if i pronounce it
right when he came across to the
continent and he built up some
relationships there political
relationships
uh which then turned to financing and
loans for the local economies and then
direct investments to the different
countries um so they they've they've
established themselves very well in
latin america now uh from mexico all the
way down to argentina uh the
relationship with some of those
countries are very um
very established and most recently with
kovid though china was the first country
to offer help in ppe and vaccinations
and all this so those some of those
nations are very grateful
so would would that turn into some kind
of um
they now to rebuild they need to rebuild
those economies so will they be going
back to china who has very um
much easier credit lines uh for
borrowing than say the us and europe
tim marshall you've um
you've written several books actually
dividing the world into maps spheres of
influence and so on um
what's your new map
uh telling us about china's influence
well it is huge and and cindy made the
point about the institutions because
it's now the shanghai
uh the the bank the banks that china put
up to to be uh in opposition to some of
the big western organizations i did want
to bring it briefly back to this russia
situation china would much rather not to
have had to have made any decisions at
the moment they were going to play a
long game with russia as the dominant
partner
russia does appear to have looked for
them to assistance and the chinese are
thinking i'm really not sure we want to
do that so that limitless friendship
that was declared between putin and zee
just
two months ago has proved to have
absolute limits and i think crucially to
try to understand
why china is so reluctant is that for
decades its policy is non-interference
in a sovereign state and what is this if
it's not interference in a sovereign
state so china is
very reluctant to get involved in this
okay rose got some more though um
we're hearing about china's influence
but nobody seems too clear about whether
they are
keen to exert that influence or whether
they want to stand back
whether they think the russians can be
controlled or whether they're even
interested in doing that what's your
view
well the chinese are walking a very thin
tightrope
and i think they don't want i agree very
much they don't want to be asked this
question right now they're not very keen
there is a rumor out there for example
that foreign minister lavrov's plane
turned around on his way to beijing last
week that's been stoutly denied by both
beijing and moscow but nevertheless it's
clear that the chinese are are tiptoeing
along this tightrope and trying to
figure out what to do president biden of
course in the united states is doing
everything that he can to
convey to the chinese that they are
going to pay a cost if they do try to
get around sanctions provide military
equipment to russia and so forth but i
think in a way he's probably also
dangling some carrots to say let's see
what we can do to work together to get
out
of this particular crisis and carry a
more positive agenda forward i think we
have to in many ways otherwise the world
economy will collapse and some major
international institutions like the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty regime
will collapse
rose thank you and let's just finally go
back to
gene
spooner on the wall jean
rose godmother says we've got to dig
ourselves out of the hole
we've been talking about
one potential
power that might help us what's your
view
well china definitely hasn't hasn't put
a foot wrong at all
they've been buying up territory all
over the world mostly a lot of us in
africa
they've um been making sure that they
they were okay and uh they don't they
must look at us and have a laugh because
um here we are weak navel gazing virtue
signaling as if we don't live in the
real world and they know that they don't
have to do what russia's doing they
don't have to kill anybody
they just make us into consumers we've
made ourselves into consumers and
they've made us into consumers so that
they see our weakness they see
everything about us the lack of dignity
the the fact that we we think we're gods
we think we think we or we all deserve
the best we
we instant gratification we're not
prepared to take the long road uh the
long windy road we just want instantly
what we want and we want it now and we
want it cheaply and they see that that's
the way to conquer the world not to
bomb anybody
all right this is the great debate up
next are countries like saudi arabia and
iran gaining influence around the world
boris johnson is about to cozy up to
saudi arabia even though they've just
executed 81 people
global turmoil reshaping global
diplomacy we have long long standing
relationships with this part of the
world should we be accepting uh more oil
from saudi arabia if it is a long-term
strategy to make us dependent on saudi
arabia instead of russia then i would
take a fundamentally different probe
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
this is the great debate where this week
we're asking
how is vladimir putin's war changing the
world
and we're looking ahead to what the
future might hold now
and i'm going to hear from
mark hill uh now mark
look ahead for us talk to us
my question is once the war is over will
russia return to its place on the world
stage
have you got a view about that mark
i'm just worried that money will take
over because um everybody's worried
about bills now will they just say
let's go back to how things is forget
everything because it's all about money
okay
mark's question
once the war is over will russia return
to its place on the world stage tim
marshall
i doubt it
financially yes we are still going to
want to buy their oil and gas but they
don't make anything else so we don't
want anything else from them so if you
put that to one side no is the answer
because we are now in a post cold a
post-post cold war era this is a
dividing line so we're not going back
um they're not going to have that place
they're not going to be a partner
under the current governmental system
i really believe this is a
watershed in relations you mentioned all
those other countries as well
we are still in a multi-polar world
we're going to go back to a form of
bipolar world and countries will fall in
most of them between one of the two
great powers the americans and the
chinese and russia is just a junior
partner for the chinese well why would
we know not go back i mean
oil is oil
it's as much oil now as it was uh
we're already buying their gas and oil
even now they're getting a billion
dollars a day they're spending about a
billion dollars a day on the war so i
mean it's a very crude example but you
could say we're bankrolling their war
we're not it's more complicated than
that but we're already buying that oil
and gas germany is already backsliding a
little bit on sanctions but
this is a dividing line what they have
done in ukraine is is of such magnitude
that there's not any coming back in the
next few years at least ash i think
tim's right what they've done there is
so horrific and
so many nations have stood up and said
they want to see vladimir putin tried
for war crimes i can't see how we could
ever normalize relations with russia in
the same way again
i also think
seeing russia's operational failures in
ukraine we run the risk of mistaking the
whole thing is going wrong for him we
have no idea what vladimir putin's
strategic objectives are now
there was his talk about whether he
wanted to capture kiev quickly and so on
but
they've also taken the entire south
coast of ukraine where it touches onto
the black sea
we've heard a lot about how russia's got
this massive information war capability
but very little of it has been directed
towards us in europe or north america i
think putin knew from the outset that
once he started this campaign he was
never going to get us onside to
believing that it was just however
they've been doing a lot of information
stuff into africa
into southeast asia into south asia
and
russia has the ability to think in the
strategic way in the long game in the
way that we just don't putin is for a
long time talked about wanting to shake
up the new world order and he's
certainly done that he may accept the
division between the authoritarian world
and the democratic world as a price that
he's willing to pay to achieve his
objectives which might just be more
influence in places like africa and
southeast asia and south asia okay
let's come back to the wall
linda porter
on the other side of this
do you think things can bounce back to
being as they were
um not the way it stands and i mean the
british people at the moment are paying
60
in fuel tax now instead of immediately
lowering that rate to ease the pressure
on the economy what do we see but
boris going capping hand to saudi
to sidle up to muhammad bin salman who
himself is responsible for recently
executing at least 81 people
isn't this
hypocritical
while sanctioning russia and condemning
putin for his barbaric actions in
ukraine
okay linda stay there carlos and rick
what what do you think about this
where is this episode going to leave us
ethically
um well uh good evening everybody um i
hope that um
it will keep us uh more united but
on the other hand there's obviously the
chance that the the divisions of um
of the political divisions will will
will prevail
um
personally i see this probably coming uh
in the last decade
um we we have
seen this is more an effect in the west
we have seen countries becoming more
isolated
we have seen
democracies becoming
[Music]
more focused on themselves than
in finding you know unity then we can
all think examples
of
the west becoming
increasingly polarized internally and
alienated with others
and this all favors only
totalitarianism okay and
so i hope that there is the possibility
to get out of this better and more
united thank you carlos cindy this is an
interesting point isn't it that we're
all united to today we're democracies
versus authoritarianism but in the
medium and long term
actually this could lead to isolationism
oh in terms of reversing globalization
yeah but we all each country starts to
look after itself i think that economic
interests are not going to let that
happen you know i think
in the way that your viewers have
already picked out you know we're going
to saudi arabia clearly ideology is not
to be on an endo of things and you know
if we're talking about moving factory
work out of china where are we moving it
to vietnam last time i checked they
weren't a democracy either so i think
economic interests are always going to
speak first and by the way that's not
necessarily a bad thing you know as your
average voters your average citizen if
you want to have a good standard of
living your government should be looking
out for your national self-interest
sometimes that's ideology but not always
sometimes that's living costs and so i'm
you know cynical and i'm sanguine and i
believe that countries should be doing
the best they can for their people and
you know sometimes ideology has to take
a back seat on that
okay rose
america has been through its own little
period of
isolationism do you think that as we've
been hearing here that the outcome of
all of this might be to force nations to
say we can't trust
uh stability in the rest of the world we
can't trust our partners so we've got to
look after
ourselves yes we've just been through
our episode of america first that's for
sure but i one thing that this crisis
has done is really produced this amazing
coherence in europe but not only in
europe and the point is well taken the
asian partners and allies uh have also
been really joining in this effort to
counter
russia economically and to throw
sanctions at it and so i think that that
coherence will i mean you mentioned yes
that germany is starting to perhaps show
a little weakness on sanctions but i
think in general the shock of this
notion that again the big autocratic
tyrant can come in and break apart what
has been a young and vibrant and growing
country
in just such a a stark way make a grab
of this kind i think has been shocking
to a lot of people around the world and
so i actually hope that there will be a
degree of coherence that comes out of
this politically for some period of time
we will see uh we will have to see what
happens but i do think that that's one
point the other point if i could trevor
just really quickly very quickly talking
about some old old guys here
69 years old who's been turned 70 this
year biden himself is in his 70s there
has to be a generation change and that's
what interests me are we going to see
some younger leaders like vlodimir
zelinsky stepping forward now in the
wake of this crisis
okay my temptation to say don't write
off people in their 60s is very strong
but that's self-interest
after the break we're looking at how
countries have responded to the
humanitarian crisis caused by the
ukraine invasion
what i saw was a human tragedy on an
epic and heartbreaking scale and i have
to tell you
it broke my heart
britain is a country that always does
right by those in need so much stuff so
much people
we try help these people because worries
worries health
yes it's political games it's diplomacy
but right now
people's lives are at stake
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations it takes 60 minutes to cross
the irish sea it took the british
monarchy essentially
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times there's no need
for this but you have to keep going
look at
you don't that
people but you do have to give them a
fact
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how is vladimir putin's war changing the
world that's what our viewers panel and
studio guests are discussing this week
and for the millions of people displaced
from ukraine it's not only the wider
world that's changing but their own
world too
let's start with elena valeeva from our
viewers panel elena
can you talk to us about your experience
because you've come from kharkiv i think
uh yeah uh i was forced to flee from
hakeem for ukraine's second largest city
which lies very close to the russian
border uh hurricane it was one of the
first places to be attacked and this
were and
i should say that russian missiles
strikes they continue to strike our
native city
and russia already has shot thousands of
civilian objects unfortunately okay
you're now in dublin um
how did you get there um
first of all we left harkief and
traveled to poland uh this journey to
poland took us nearly for the east uh
but when in poland where uh me and my
cousin we didn't know uh where we could
go next and we were stuck in poland and
uh to tell the truth the truth we were
uh in the desperate and we were stranded
and we didn't know what to do next
okay and then uh
yeah okay you you have a question for
our panel i think
uh yeah i have a question uh my question
is has the ukraine invasion encouraged
cooperation between other countries
thank you later
the last question for the panel is
uh has the ukraine invasion encourage
cooperation between other countries ash
i think
one of the things that vladimir putin
hates more than anything is alliances he
likes countries that are clients of his
that do what he tells them to do
and this has shown the value of
alliances showing value of nato in the
european union and how cooperating
allows smaller countries to resist that
kind of
negative influence
and the way the european union has
responded together to the challenges the
military challenge the political
challenge and the humanitarian challenge
has really been quite impressive it's i
think been a lot more powerful and
positive than anyone expected it to be
and
it's a shame that it's required a
tragedy to do this but i do see
countries working together much better
than they have done in recent years
tim do you agree and do you think that's
model for the future or just this one
time i'm reluctant to disagree but i
actually slightly
only slightly disagree
the european union has not had a good
war
diplomatically
it has been the nation states that have
responded mostly individually but we
will take x we will do why it i don't
think it's being though there is
coordination there there there there
people are talking to each other but
it's mostly been individual countries
whether it's germany pretty much
changing its foreign policy after 70
years of neutrality or whether it's
poland opening its doors in a
magnificent way but i think it's been
done at the nation-state level now
that's not to say that the european
union has not actually been strengthened
by this crisis by realizing they must
stick together otherwise they will fall
apart
okay let's go back to our panel and talk
to elaine
hamilton
um
elaine what do you think about this
question of
whether countries are cooperating more
effectively
um well i think the uk scheme
of 350 pounds a month to help people
take in refugees is good
um but it has come a little too late
and i'm not sure it's generous enough
i live on a pension and i have a spare
room
and i'm thinking of volunteering
but i'm very worried about the rising
cost of living
and how it might impact on my finances
uh
cindy
where do you from where you stand do you
think uh do you agree
with ash all with tim that
this has been such a jolt
that there's going to be
a kind of different spirit of
cooperation or not well i think both ash
and him are right
it's a crowd-pleasing answer but if i
can add another dimension where
cooperation is not happening is that
before the war we thought that india and
israel were western allies and i think
the war has shown that actually nations
have their own interests if you look at
india and israel both of them voted
abstained on that u.n resolution that
russia put forward because both of them
have different relationships with russia
you know israel in the middle east needs
russia as a balance against iran india
needs russian arms and you know it's
easy to think of the world as liberal
democracy versus authoritarianism but
it's more complicated than that and even
democracies like india and israel we
can't really rely on and president
biden's doing all he can to put pressure
on countries like that but i think it
just goes to show at the end of the day
it's your national interest so that is
the little bone of contention where
cooperation is not happening all right
rose
what do you think
do you think this has given us a shock
on the west
whether we describe that in terms of
values and ideology or geography do you
think this episode has given us
a shock that will bring us together
for good or is this just something
that's going to happen in a sort of rush
of generosity and solidarity with
ukrainians
i think the future is going to have to
tell on this you know we were famously
and i will say here coming out of world
war ii and building up our institutions
and caring for shattered europe we were
famously joined together in putting the
marshall plan on the table the united
states of course took the lead in
putting a lot of resources on the table
to rebuild europe but others joined as
they could and uh i think that kind of
spirit and momentum led to the original
uh founding institutions that led to the
to uh the european union so there was a
lot of momentum that came out of efforts
in world war ii to do the right thing
and i know in the united states they're
talking about again a marshall plan for
ukraine to build rebuild that shattered
nation after this terrible invasion and
i hope we have a peace settlement and
the russians get out but i know that the
united states is intent on getting
others of its allies and partners to
join in helping to finance a recovery
for ukraine and a rebuilding for it so
looking to the future i see
yes that there will be ways that we can
stay cemented together it won't be easy
however but i hope that spirit of the
marshall plan will carry us forward
thank you rose godmother
i'm afraid that's all we have time for
this evening just remains for me to
thank our panelists here in the studio
ash bhardwaj cindy you
tim marshall and from south carolina
guerrero's gotta
of course it's you at home who are at
the center of this conversation
on next week's episode we're asking
is racism in sport here to stay
if you want to be part of that
discussion you can get in touch by
emailing
the great debate at sky dot uk
for now i want to thank everybody on
tonight's viewers panel on the wall for
your thoughtful contributions thank you
and of course to you at home keep
talking we'll see you again at the same
time next week for the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]
you